shares in saudi-arabia state-run oil
company have officially begun trading on
Riyadh Stock Exchange opening 10% higher
than the initial public offering
Saudi Aramco made history a week ago
with the largest ever IPO raising twenty
five point six billion dollars for less
than two percent of the company
this valued Aramco at one point seven
trillion dollars making it the most
valuable listed company in the world
the IPO fell short of the two trillion
valuation the kingdom had wanted though
officials hope it will hit that mark on
the first day of trading let's speak to
Evander nihari about this she's a
founder and CEO of Vanda inside starts
the company providing global oil markets
analysis she's live from Singapore thank
you so much for being with us on al
Jazeera a very good start for Aramco
who's manipulating the markets to get
the stock price up to two trillion
dollars well to some extent the IPO from
the start the process was very carefully
stage-managed the expectations had been
whittled down quite a bit from compared
with the initial aspirations to list 5%
of the company with the total valuation
of two trillion which would have netted
the kingdom about a hundred billion
dollars the IPO the scaled-down IPO has
brought in just about 26 billion it was
expected to be listed simultaneously on
international prominent international
exchanges as well as the domestic
exchange it has been listed only on the
domestic exchange and bought only by the
southeast with a little bit of
contribution from the UAE and Kuwait so
it is a success a limited success as you
were just mentioning in your
introduction how to get the valuation up
from the 1.7 trillion which was achieved
in the IPO to the 2 trillion and I
suppose to a large extent how does Saudi
Arabia now make up for the 75 billion
dollars that it probably expected to get
but but didn't I think those are going
to be the big questions going forward
so should international investors still
be concerned about getting into the
stock and the Saudi market the
international investors will be watching
this very closely again it's the world's
most profitable company the biggest
crude exporter it has its IPO its debut
has made a new record a bigger than
Alibaba which was which held the
previous record so on a lot of metrics
it is a company that will be very
closely watched by the international
investors probably more out of a fear of
missing out on something that might be
good but by and large so far the
international investors interest has
been very tepid to say the least
that was one of the reasons even in the
final days Saudi Arabia cancelled the
international road shows up a plant for
four US and Europe and Asia so but will
they will they keep an eye they will
probably but with the valuation that has
been achieved with us very limited
offering in the domestic market is
probably not evaluation that the
international investors will go by they
have their own estimates which until now
have been pretty much lower than where
the the valuation is suggested as of as
of today so so will the Saudis in your
view achieve their goal of diversifying
their economy with the proceeds from
this IPO so as I mentioned the proceeds
have been much smaller than they might
have expected we just had the Saudi
budget announced earlier this week and
clearly they're looking at a bigger
budget deficit they're looking at much
lesser oil revenues already oil revenues
in 2019 came in nearly 10 percent below
what they had budgeted so all of those
are going to be major concerns they will
need to be looking for more money will
it help in the diversification efforts
yes probably but not but not as much as
it would have let's say had they managed
to raise a hundred billion dollars
instead of twenty six billion thank you
so much for your insight
Donna Hari who's a global oil market
analyst joining us there from Singapore
thank you for your time